foreign
[Music]
I know you and me like we were like used
to be like obsessed with [ __ ] Howard
Stern you know back in the day like
driving to work and [ __ ] we used to talk
about him oh what'd he say today like
him talking about like he was like he
like loved the show early on dude and it
was like the biggest [ __ ] deal in the
world but I think like that's what I
like when I did his show that's what
like I was like I still don't have me on
the show dude I don't know why I think
it's because like his his wife's like in
love with you man that's not it okay
he's talking about that a bunch bro yeah
this is what happens right next to her
out of [ __ ] thing I was like normally
what are you [ __ ] I didn't because
you don't listen I know you for you
you're like [ __ ] Norman but like but
they did oh my God that's Beth I'm gonna
sit next to bed yeah
and like I think it was like I'm a cat
fanatic they sat next to us we talked
about cats maybe three minutes yeah then
the movie started nice to meet you nice
too he talked about that for like two
hours bro I was in tears I was so bummed
yeah he'll have you on he went from like
loving me or loving the show yeah and
maybe the character of it to like he
went off and I was like no yeah you know
I was like No and then and then you know
I did the serious round and on serious
radio
and uh you know it's like [ __ ] an
ungodly early morning hour and they're
you know they're like so uh can you say
uh Norman Rita said you're listening to
the Howard Stern Show and I'm like uh
hey I'm no reason you know half awake
and then he he played that and he goes
sounds like I got a [ __ ] gun to his
head and I was like oh I just can't win
with this guy what's up yeah yeah I have
a creepy little voice it's super early
in the morning oh man yeah I was so
bummed I was like no no and then and
then we had an episode of the show that
was like very dark yeah you know I mean
it's dark like that he said I don't see
anything yeah I was like No And then I
told gimple I was like dude send him
screeners yeah before the show comes out
yeah so he'll talk about us he's got
like a bazillion listeners yeah he's a
fan of the show send it to him Scott's
like of course I will yeah didn't yeah
and I'm like you know and Wolfie every
once in a while check in did he get him
did he get him yeah
into him like somewhere right like we
ran and we were like I ran into Baba
Booey at the White House what was that
uh at the uh uh White House
correspondence yeah yeah and uh
and we talked for a second and uh
you know and it and then my publicist I
was like oh yeah I spoke to Baba Booey
and Howard does not want you on the show
why just just doesn't want him on the
show I'm like oh dude you know I was
like all right whatever you know what I
mean but that was fun going back and
forth going did he listen did he listen
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I I I look at
him man and I look at I look at like
just like where he would like we would
be so stoked ah we would be like did you
hear what he said it was amazing and we
got Andy [ __ ] listening you know yeah
like yeah and then he had Jeffrey D uh
Jeffrey Morgan on the show did have him
everybody but me everybody everybody
with me
it is [ __ ] up yeah did I tell you
about like how I was in series that time
and I heard it was like the day after I
died on on uh on Walking Dead no that's
so like right after I got right after I
got killed from like got me the [ __ ] out
of there and I had to like go do press
and and uh I was in the serious building
making the rounds you know and everybody
there knew how big of a [ __ ] fan I
was yeah and I'm like hanging around
like doing doing like the [ __ ]
[ __ ] show shows with like like six
people [ __ ] you know was like and uh
you know I was like I was downstairs I
was with like the serious rep and uh all
of a sudden like Howard and [ __ ]
Ronnie walk out of their studio and
they're like walking by and I'm like
holy [ __ ] and the guy's like oh there's
Howard there's Howard I was like I know
[ __ ] it's like like just shut up
and he's like walking [ __ ] by and as
it got closer I heard them and Howard's
like so I don't understand like why did
they kill like was he always a zombie or
like how did he turn into a zombie that
quick they were [ __ ] talking about me
bro and Ronnie was like trying to
explain to him with the show and the
guy's like yo they're [ __ ] talking
about you they're [ __ ] talk I'm like
I know man just shut the [ __ ] up and let
me enjoy this [ __ ] and you're like
walking by and they're like they're
[ __ ] talking about me and they like
walk right by me and the guy's like you
should say something you should and you
know it's like you never [ __ ] bother
Howard in the Halls like he always says
that like there's nothing he hates more
I'm like just let him [ __ ] be like
let me have this [ __ ] moment you
[ __ ] turd and he like keeps walking
and they're talking about me and then
the guy the serious rep is like Hey
Howard and like he just stops you know
he's like a giant you know I mean he
like stops and he like [ __ ] turns
around and he's like looking and then
the [ __ ] guy doesn't say anything no
he doesn't say anything so he's like
looking and I'm like walk over to Howard
and I'm like you know like I gotta do
this I'm like hi Mr Stern my name's my
name is John Bernthal I think you guys
were just talking about he's like oh my
God oh my God we were just talking about
you and I'm like yeah you know I know
man I I heard you and and he was like oh
you're great you know I watched the show
and I was like yeah no I know I heard
that and he was like so [ __ ] nice to
me like all he wanted to know was like
did I have another job like well yeah
you know like you know I was like dude
it's over like this is I thought for
sure it was like that was that was it
man like I it was it was all coming to a
fight like it was like and I was fine
with it I was like dude it was great you
know what I mean
[Music]
foreign
[Music]